[Musique]
neuf étudiants sur dix en entrant en
faculté de pharmacie
jeudi ce qu'a fait de leur doctorat ils
vont ouvrir une officine de pharmacie et
dispenser des médicaments
c'est dommage mais ce n'est pas
totalement de leur faute
non seulement parce que nous avons été
conditionnés pouces là mais également
parce que nous possédons pas réellement
de role model dont pourrait s'inspirer
mais avant de continuer on va d'abord
parler du pharmacien comme il est connu
sous nos cieux
vous savez ce beau jeune homme ou cette
belle dame dans sa blouse blanche
derrière le comptoir
c'est vrai que lorsque vous entrez dans
une officine de pharmacie
tout le monde est en blanc mais que vous
voyez le pharmacien je sais pas ce avait
là un flou il a un truc et ça ne ment
pas c'est donc à ce titulaire d'un
doctorat en pharmacie que les gens
attribuent à tort le banal statut de
vendeur de médicaments
c'est donc le moment pour moi de vous
dire que le pharmacien d'officine
c'est le dispensateur du médicament par
excellence
je n'ai pas dit distributeurs je n'ai
pas dit vendeur j'ai dit dispensateur
dispensation impliquant l'acte de
délivrance qui consiste à remettre des
médicaments aux patients mais également
à lui procurer les conseils associés au
bon usage de ce médicament
par ailleurs le pharmacien d'officine
c'est également le professionnel de
santé de proximité proximité parce que
c'est celui que après chaude soirée de
samedi
en tête à tête monsieur n'a pas pu se
contenir et il a quand même libéré la
semaine à l'intérieur de madame qui est
dans sa zone rouge quand ça se passe là
c'est le pharmacien concours noir mais
également à 2 heures du matin quand le
bébé chauffer que la jeune maman ne sait
pas forcément comment faire cherche la
pharmacie de garde
faut aller voir le pharmacien lui dit tu
es mon bébé chauffe depuis deux ans je
ne sais pas quoi faire professionnels de
santé de proximité parce que c'est le
gars que vous allez voir ça jamais
prendre de rendez vous suffit de vous
rendre dans une pharmacie mensonges
peuvent adopter s'il vous plaît s'ils
saluent le beau gosse laval a plu par
son beau gosse mais également parce que
tout ce que nous nous avons tout ça les
familles c'est ça les arrange pas mais
nous avons tout ça pour les voir et
pharmaciens c'est gratuit zéro frais de
consultation à pays
je vais même plus loin en vous disant
que derrière chaque acte de dispensation
de la plus simple la quête de
paracétamol ou à l'anti perdre en soit
le plus cher le phare massé a une
responsabilité qui est automatiquement
engagé lorsqu'il vous remet un
médicament
cette responsabilité peut être civile
est parfois plus graves et les pénal
vous convenait donc avec moi que c'est
vraiment un crime le cliché le
pharmacien d'officine de vendeurs de
médicaments
j'aime raconter une petite histoire du
roman q 682 pharmacie on a encore des
nommés déontologie pharmaceutique et
dans ce cours il ya un chapitre intitulé
les métiers du pharmacien
j'ai vu le déroulé du programme est
saisi il se fout de moi ce gars il dit
mais thierry pharmaciens qu'est-ce qu'il
veut m'apprendre le 26 juillet la zone
dr eyes installé puis tout le monde en
avait qu'est-ce qu'ils vont m'apprendre
donc par curiosité je suis secours et
comment vous dire que ce cours a juste
été pour moi une bénédiction
je venais de découvrir la façon que je
pouvais me démarquer exprimer ma
différence et surtout emmener les gens à
respecter la profession que j'ai choisi
d'exercer ne sais pas si tantôt vous
avez remarqué que j'ai chaque fois parlé
de pharmaciens d'officine et non
pharmacien tout court parce que grâce à
ce court et déontologie j'ai su que le
pharmacien pour être militaire
entrepreneur
communicateur de santé biologistes
chercheurs cosmétologues autant de
choses que peut faire le pharmacien sous
sa belle blouse là on n'avait pas idée
du nombre de facettes biya ça c'est sûr
mais mis à part cet aspect il m'est
apparu très important de pouvoir montrer
à mes jeunes confrères entrée en faculté
de pharmacie toutes les opportunités qui
nous sont offertes
je n'ai vraiment plus envie de voir un
jeune en voulant s'inscrire à moi je
vais mais ce prix parce que tu veux ma
femme assise à côté de la boutique de
mam en matière d'eau non on depuis ça
parce que ça tue les talents ça tulle et
alain et c'est dommage qu'on voit la
multitude d'opportunités que nous avons
vous allez me demander mais pourquoi tu
veux les inspirer alors que comme toi
ils auront surtout de déontologie femmes
asiatiques
je vous dirai pourquoi à l'époque en 4e
année nous étions 15
oui parce que platon pharmacie sous toit
cotonou vous passer de 85 étudiants à 55
rue après vous le tollé à 15 autour de
15-20 donc nous étions 15 et ce cours là
à impacter juste quatre d'entre nous
mais à l'estampé je ne peux pas vous
dire que nous sommes toujours 4 être
autant motivés être différent parce que
certains ont peur de l'échec
certains ont peur de sortir de leur zone
de confort certains n'ont pas encore les
moyens de le faire nous allons faire
donc le bilan de trois points principaux
le premier était de montrer à quel point
le famas et un professionnel de santé de
proximité
le second était de montrer que le
pharmacien n'est pas un banal vendeurs
de médicaments
le troisième est de faire découvrir à
mes pairs toutes les facettes du
pharmacien mai et dans la foulée de
faire connaître au public tout ce que
peut faire le pharmacien donc je me
disais qu'il fallait faire quelque chose
mais quoi et pour moi je ne savais pas
trop et puis il s'est passé quelque
chose en février 2010 est en baisse chez
le pharmacien
la fameuse saisie des 85 de faux
médicaments
ça n'a échappé à personne encore moins
celui que je qualifie de ma plus belle
rencontre 2017 qui m'a dit
ça va lui ça va tu as vu qu'on a saisi
des médicaments des fonds mais il
cherche à lui fais ok tu vas faire quoi
j'ai fait faire quoi jean yves est tu as
pharmacienne ou pas je fais ici mais
malgré ce pas d'art il dit je sais pas
comment tu vas faire des bruits toi il
faut que tu fasses quelque chose je
venais de trouver le climat vous avez
créé qui s'échauffe le ping pour que tu
vas donc c'est comme ça qu'à travers à
travers ma page personnelle facebook
j'ai commencé à partager via le hashtag
pharma news les informations de santé
mais beaucoup plus axé sur le médicament
ayant eu des réactions positives des
encouragements et surtout dans le but
d'améliorer la qualité de mon contenu
asma santé j'ai créé en août 2007 à 60
et une plateforme digitale qui à travers
de contenu diversifié diversifiée des
visuels des photos des vidéos ou encore
des textes délivre une information de
santé has ma santé présents sur twitter
instagram facebook mais également sur
médium dans un langage dans un langage
en adéquation avec les réalités de notre
temps être présente en fait sur autant
de canaux n'a pas pour but pour moi
uniquement d'atteindre le maximum de
personnes
asma santé m chaque jour à exprimer un
peu plus ma différence à l'assumer et je
l'espère a poussé d'autres personnes a
sortis de leur zone de confort donc
étant dans un élan de curiosité j'ai
commencé à participer à des événements
pharmaceutique dans la sous région et
non dessous d inspiration si vous en
cherchez sortait chine
vous allez retrouver à foison ailleurs
des pharmaciens son ministre
d'autres sont députés d'autres encore
comme le professeur daouda n'diaye
pharmacie chercheurs sénégalais sont
donnés à harvard qui l'a promis d'être
nommé à un vin avec les vrais salaires
qui vont avec
en tout cas moi j'en ai envie c'est à ce
moment là je le dis pourquoi lui et pas
moi
pourquoi lui et pas moi
ils font
forcément faire quelque chose quand j'en
parle à mes collègues ils disent non ça
c'est des parce que je reste dans un
contexte africain
ils vont te dire non ça c'est des
sénégalaises
si les ivoiriens l' écosystème est plus
favorable à sable donc ils veulent les
exemples du bénin là vous en donner à
relizane pharmacien il a créé une
application mobile de santé docteur
achilli et moi qui est devenu depuis le
9 novembre dernier le premier maître de
conférences agrégé de pharmacie à
cotonou c'est un pharmacien c'est un
béninois il a été formé ici
donc pourquoi lui et pas moi à oui si la
femme âgée aussi peuvent être agrégées
s'est pas uniquement pour les médecins
donc c'est là que je me dis que c'est
important que les gens sachent que vous
sachiez que le pharmacien peut faire
beaucoup de choses bien au delà de ce
que vous pensez le pharmacien comme le
médecin peut se spécialiser dans une
vingtaine de domaines
donc pourquoi gardé cette information
pour moi plus vous partagez et plus vous
gagnez c'est ce que j'ai décidé de faire
approuver à 60 et j'espère être celle
qui aidera à franchir le par qui que tu
sois j'espère être celle qui te motive
sera assorti d'état zone de confort à
pousser toutes les portes qui nous sont
ouvertes en tant que pharmacien pour
qu'ensemble on puisse contribuer au bien
être de notre communauté
j'espère surtout que vous en sortant
d'ici vous partirez avec un nouveau
visage du patient est ancré dans vos
esprits
je suis un homme amazon je suis
pharmacienne 2.0 et j'ai choisi d'être
différente
[Applaudissements]